all right well turning now to jared leto
and our special correspondent kelsey
night was invited inside the oscar
winners hollywood studio for a very rare
and revealing new interview it looks
like a mess but studios should be a mess
it's a big day for the 45 year old and
his band thirty Seconds to Mars today is
the release of their first single in
four years called walk on water
[Music]
have you been paying attention to their
reaction today not everything because
that's a good way to end to end up in
the hospital that's right next to
googling yourself this is how much
Jared's changed since his first days in
the band - now fans well they're still
insatiable some other people climb the
fence to your house and are sleeping in
your bed and you have to have them
removed by security despite all that
Jared made this my so-called life
confession do you ever watch the old
episodes on Hulu and Netflix it don't
you have so much in your career yeah do
you think about coming a husband do you
think about having cancer yeah I'm sure
it would be fantastic to have kids do
you never know you may get the knock at
the door one day and say hey Jared
surprise guess what I mean yeah that
could be fun - sounds like an open
invite ladies jared is single but here's
a tip he likes his hugs to be a
full-body embrace you see how she did
that because I wanted to make sure I
know it was beside Jesus just get there
I mean Kelsey what were you thinking I
mean you know it's Jared